welcome back everyone to another
speedrun episode I know it's been a
little while since I last posted in this
series if you missed my last several
uploads you'll know that I just finished
a very strong tournament in Qatar it was
a Kar Masters and in that tournament I
was playing high rated opponents every
single game nine rounds of classical
chess so it will be a little bit weird
transitioning from that to the speedrun
account where my rating is
561 but if you're new to watching the
series the way this works is I start on
a fresh account I did start at a 400 ELO
and I'll try to work my way up as high
as possible so I have updated my profile
picture uh we have baby me uh I think
this was taken when I was 2 years old so
maybe
1995 is um as I progress through the
series I'll be updating my photo to
hopefully show the progression of how
I've aged over the last 30 years so
anyway let's hop into a game now I do
want to note this will be 10-minute
chests and every opponent who I play uh
their rating will get refunded okay so
we have E4
E5 um as usual I will stick with some
classical openings stick with the
openings I recommend for this r level
and yeah as as usual my opponent uh
deviating from Mainline opening Theory
now this move is not a blunder uh
because it does defend the pawn but
generally black should not be moving the
queen out on move two and basically the
way to punish a move like Queen F6 is
simply to bring out the minor
pieces and hopefully very soon we'll see
the downside of black having brought out
the queen early so basically what I can
do is start exploiting the queen um now
I do have an option here of playing
Knight D5 right away the issue with
Knight D5 assuming my opponent sees the
queen is attacked is they could move
back and then later play C6 and then I'm
going to lose time moving my knight so I
think a more productive move here is
Pawn
D4 uh very simply trying to open the
center and also having idea of getting
the bishop to G5 now of course okay I
should deal with the pawn capture first
I'll take with the
Knight um this is nice CU Queen supports
the
Knight and yeah I have two knights
developed black only has a queen
developed now one downside is I no
longer have Bishop
G5 but okay now now I have some options
because
even though my knight is
attacked I don't have to move
it I'm debating here between okay Knight
B5 does look nice just simply
threatening the fork there's also Knight
D5 which hits the queen and thrs the
fork on C7 I guess this question how
tricky I want to be because if I play
Knight
D5 then black can take and take and take
and I probably win material in the end
but then my knight could get
stuck and to keep things simple because
really this is
uh at this rating level you don't want
to over overthink things too much I'm
just going to play Knight
B5 simply saving the Knight now
threatening the
fork and we'll see if black can defend
here and there's not too many moves to
defend so A6 this is a very typical
beginner mistake uh attacking the Knight
but not
acknowledging my threat and now yeah
I'll be picking up the Rook next
move I will be showing no
mercy black has three legal moves
here take the
rook and nice thing with the pawn having
committed here my knight can escape via
B6 there are cases
uh where sometimes when I take the Rook
the Knight could get trapped but looks
like the Knight will be escaping to uh
to live on for a little bit
longer now there's another idea here of
bringing the Knight to D5 which has been
idea since I brought the Knight to
C3
and I guess I I have to decide like do I
want to bring this Knight back do I want
to bring this Knight forward do I want
to be sneaky and play H5 to prepare
Bishop
G5 H4 I should
say um or do I just want to develop like
Bishop C4 bring another piece into play
get ready to Castle there are I think a
lot of fine options for
Whit um I'm most inclined to bring this
Knight back I think this is the simplest
approach because I wanton a rook and I
want to make sure that I'm not losing
anything
ideally I would like to trade like
Knight takes C8 or Knight
D5 um yeah let's play Knight
D5 and even though I've moved this
Knight A lot of times this Knight has
gone from G1 to D4 to B5 to C7 to a to
B6 and now it's traded off um but every
single knight move has been with a clear
purpose and now this Knight is extra
strong hitting the queen
we'll probably see Queen what queen E5
Queen E6 it's a handful of say squares
that the queen could move
to I think both of us this game have not
done a great job of like being efficient
with
development uh of course for me I I
broke some principles cuz it was
justified in winning material but now
it's time
to actually complete my development I
like the move Bishop to D3 simply
defending the
pawn preparing to
Castle Queen G6 while
castle Yeah defending the pawn on
G2 now going forward from here it's
still a question how to convert my extra
Rook into eventually winning the
game and of of course like trading is is
one way to try and
simplify uh but in a position like this
especially with Mye King pretty safe and
Black's King in the center not castling
uh Sometimes the best strategy is to try
and organize an
attack um but of course to attack I need
to get more pieces into
play um or just wait for my opponent to
resign okay I guess my opponent did not
want to uh suffer much longer there
uh so what's the lesson to take away
from this game black should have uh
rather than playing Queen F6 should have
played Knight C6 in the opening this is
really the the standard
move um and I think we saw the downside
with Black's opening
play he kicked my knight early but
allowed me to get the early tactic and
in this position I I did want to make a
note that uh the way for black to defend
here it's it's not pretty and there's
really not too many options but there
are maybe a couple reasonable moves uh
one is Knight A6 and even though it's
usually bad to put the Knight on the
edge of the board it does cover Knight
C7 uh the other move would be Queen d8
just kind of undoing the previous queen
move but again covering C7 and if we saw
this move or or this move I was going to
bring my knight to D5 and essentially
black would have to
have the Knight and the queen
controlling C7 to effectively
defend and this would still be good for
white but uh I don't think White's
winning any material here so this would
have been more of a fight but anyway um
pretty quick game there that was 13
moves so let's play another
one I'll hop in the
pool and white again playing Alex Murray
74 I'll play
E4 and okay we'll repeat the same oops
sorry for hitting the mic repeating the
same opening this time opponent plays uh
the best move Knight C6 and I will play
Bishop to C4 Italian opening there are
there's a lot of options for white even
like on the third move but also in this
position uh there's a f liver there's D3
there's Knight
C3 I think i' I mentioned or I showed in
a previous game Knight C3 does run into
the center fork trick I think that was a
previous episode of the speed run so I'm
going to play uh the very solid and
probably one of the most common moves
Pawn D3 leading into a more typical
Italian Knight G5 of course is a more
aggressive approach leading to a fried
liver but D3 simply defends the pawn
prepares to develop the
bishop and this is one of the first
openings I played as like a young child
um I I played this opening with a very
clear plan in mind and I think I'll try
and demonstrate that plan going forward
from here so I'm going to play Knight
C3 um now there's no Center of work
trick Knight takes E4 I can take back
with Pawn uh but here my opponent is
actually trying to attack me right away
Knight F2 or Knight takes F2 is a threat
um also Bishop takes F2 of course uh now
in this
position uh Knight G4 is not actually a
great approach for black very simply
because white can
castle and I really don't mind if black
takes twice on F2 we might see this play
out I did want to note that if the
Knight were to stay on F6 like going
back here if black were to Castle my
plan was going to be Bishop G5 and
Knight
D5 and uh yeah when I was younger I I
won a lot of games with that plan but we
do see Knight takes F2 and I think this
will be very instructive because uh from
a a pure point value perspective when
when we think about how much the pieces
are worth uh black traded Knight and
Bishop for rook and pawn so you would
think that's six points for six
points uh but pieces aren't always
directly match their values especially
earlier in the game and generally in the
opening and middle game the minor pieces
are much more valuable than Rook uh
simply
because uh the Rooks take long time to
actually
activate and my minor pieces in this
position can hopefully very quickly
orchestrate some
attack uh but it's still a question how
to proceed from here and I would really
like to develop my Bishop I'd like to
move Bishop to G5 I'm going to play this
because there's
no it's not legal for black to play Pawn
F6 because the F Pawn is pinned so black
has to either play this or this to Save
the
Queen and with both moves it's it's
already looking a little bit ugly for
black I think my followup is going to be
Knight
D5 yeah I think we're already seeing the
consequences of Black's uh trade on F2 I
remember when I first saw this like as a
a younger player it did look scary
because the King on F2 seems very
exposed um but the thing is the king
isn't weak if the opponent can't exploit
it and in this case there's really no
great way for black to exploit my king
and meanwhile while yeah it's Black's
pieces who are getting exploited here so
now the Knight is pinned and attacked
twice um now I should note when I play
Knight D5 I do block my Bishop so this
makes F6
available but the problem is if black
plays F6 I'm going to have a discover
check against the
king so I actually don't see a great way
for black
to get out of this
sorry I just had some Vietnamese food
some food stuck in my
teeth what to do I might cut that out or
not I don't know okay so we do see F6 so
now we're in a position where any single
or any night move I play uh there's what
eight legal moves with this Knight so
every single knight move will be a
check uh now the most obvious approach
just seems to take the Knight and that
would be double
check but I want to pause here and just
make
sure if I take the Knight black is going
to play this and then my knight and
Bishop will be
hanging so I might have to
concede some material back the other
approach is I can take the pawn Force
the king here and then move back and try
and win the Knight
um yeah there's a
couple couple nice looking approaches
here yeah the thing is after takes here
I guess I could take the
bishop yeah that might be the simplest
and then then we're
trading although black takes
here I then my knight is
trapped yeah I don't want to overthink
this too
much but
I do want to like play the the most
principled approach I'm actually leaning
towards taking the
pawn even though it's going to open the
f file does look a little bit scary
taking the pawn will force King h8 and
then I'll move back and black is in the
same
predicament I should be
winning winning a lot of material
there and yeah the nice thing about
double check is the King has to move
there's no way to like block the check
or capture because there's two pieces
attacking the king uh so this is the
only legal
move generally when you have only one
legal move you should you should realize
the situation you were in and play it
pretty
quickly yeah the bishop can't be blocked
either so okay now I'll move back
and now there's no Pawn to obstruct my
bishop and yeah there's not really any
easy way for black to exploit my king I
mean my Knight's
pinned it'd be nice if uh it would be
nice for black to jump over the Knight
and take the bishop but that's not quite
legal this is not spell
chest and even if the Rook tries to
defend the Knight I'm going to take and
uh yeah I'll be be up a at least a minor
piece after all said and
done another thing I want to mention is
with my king on
F2 uh generally if I do have time I
would like to put it back on G1
essentially get the king back to the
castle Square even sometimes go to H1
where it would be the safest but for now
that's um it's not really
necessary and now I do want to share I'm
not sure if uh this will play out in the
way I'm dreaming of but with my Bishop
already on a very nice diagonal and
potentially controlling this G8 square
there's going to be some possible mating
ideas especially if my queen can come in
especially if I can get a knight to
G6 so I'm imagining like if I do take on
E7 and maybe get my king back and either
get my queen to H5 or maybe maneuver to
H4 then the combination of Queen Bishop
on C4 and then Knight coming to G6 could
be some pretty brutal
checkmates but uh yeah still many moves
away from that happening I'm hoping at
least one game in this episode will end
with checkmates maybe I'll keep playing
games until I get uh one Checkmate on
the board hoping the opponent doesn't
resign here
but I do understand like sometimes when
you get a losing position from early on
it's it's not always the most fun to
play
out but one tip I will give
for for newer players is if you are
losing you should play it out cuz a lot
of players do struggle to convert
winning
positions and yeah when I was younger my
my chess coach H rule for me like never
resign and that's one
I think that's one of the ways I learned
how to just put up a lot of resistance
from really bad or losing
positions and over the years I've I've
saved a lot of positions even much worse
than this from the black
side opponent's taking time
maybe maybe trying to find their their
Miracle resource maybe just
[Music]
crying this is one reason
why I sometimes like over theboard chess
more than online chess it's online it's
just a Time ticking nothing's really
happening but over theboard chess you
can you can see your opponent
suffer okay now do I want to actually
take the Knight so I'm realizing with
the last
move I have another
option of Knight takes
Pawn
and this can lead
to the potential
Fork I don't think I'm really risking
much like when I take the pawn I do
allow Rook f8 check but then I can move
back to
G1 and then
meanwhile yeah the knight's still pinned
I'm going to take the
pawn like even though taking on E7 with
either piece would have won material
in general you don't necessarily have to
take a pinned piece right away CU yeah
the piece can't really
move and rather than catching a small
fish I want to catch one of these big
fish all my minor
pieces I me this is a dream scenario
with uh just having all the minor pieces
applying maximum pressure from early on
like every single piece is playing a
role like even though this bishop is
blocked it's hopefully GNA play a role
pretty
soon so move back to
G1 and I'm not getting in Knight F7 as I
was hoping but but now the Knight is is
less defended so Bishop takes E7 as a
monster
threat not to mention my Queen's ready
to come
in so there's going to be ideas of like
Knight G
six maybe
eventually okay so the Rook moves back
and now I do have the fork I'm looking
for for potential mates
but yeah mate will be coming especially
like once I win the queen I think
everything is going to crumble for
black at King G8 is only leg go move
here it's possible we'll see resignation
cuz this this gets really bad like King
G8 I take and then uh the Knight will be
hanging yeah okay so 15 moves I think
this is a very important lesson goes to
show
why this trade is not good especially
for the side that it's conceding the
minor
pieces and in a similar manner um I had
the same option to play Knight G5 in
this position
and this is not effective for the same
reason because back in Castle and after
takes takes takes
takes uh then it's black getting the
minor pieces two minor pieces for rook
and pawn uh this would be much
preferable for black so I hope I hope
this lesson is valuable to people
watching because I I know there's a lot
of people out there that think it's a
fair trade and maybe would think that
it's good to expose a king like this but
um yeah usually in the middle game
actually in most stages of the game uh
two minor pieces are more valuable than
rook and
pawn um going back to this position I
want to note that Knight G5 is a
perfectly acceptable move um because
black can't Castle to defend and this is
just a a main line it's um yeah the
basically the fried liver attack after
D5 and after takes the main line is
Knight A5 um if you want to see my my
comments about this line you can see the
previous episode of the
speedrun but uh yeah let's move on nice
instructive game do at least one
more I'm hoping by the end of this video
I'll I'll reach 600 ELO so now I'm black
play
E5 yeah I think with a lot of of games
early in the series we'll see a lot of
these King Pawn openings but now we have
something a little bit fresh we have um
the beginning of a center game could be
the beginning of a Danish
Gambit uh now this is what we call the
center game Queen takes
D4 and yeah generally with this opening
Knight C6 is just definitely the most
principled attacking the
queen queen moves back so this is
already some success uccess white has
essentially wasted a couple moves moving
the queen up and back and that's giving
me time to get a pretty early lead in
development and I want to note um this
might seem like very obvious but there
are different types of advantages in
chests uh of course like a big Advantage
is material if you have more pieces than
your opponent or more powerful pieces
than your opponent you you're likely to
have the advant
but another type of Advantage is just
having more pieces developed or just
having more active pieces and in this
case that might translate into some
material advantage uh a bit later so
light's being a little bit
slow and yeah generally in this um this
early phase of the game we just want to
activate the minor pieces get the king
safe and then yeah hopefully I can
punish white for being a little bit slow
to develop
here and with Knight F6 not only am I
preparing to Castle but I am attacking
the undefended pawn on
e4 so the best move here for white I
would think is to play Knight C3 just
develop the Knight and defend the
pawn or Bishop
D3 oh no my opponent
disconnected will allo resign in 20
seconds and this isn't a winning
position
for for black it's slightly
better but my advantage is temporary
like if white can play Bishop D3 Knight
C3 just focus on getting the minor
pieces out and
castled then that white could very much
be in the game but uh I won by
abandonment okay uh this episode might
have a lot of games but okay hopefully
there is at least a couple lessons to
take away there with uh the the early
opening sequence let's play another
game playing Scotty boy
91 and we'll have another King's Pawn
opening I think four games so far and
four King Pawn openings play Knight
C6 Okay so
what do I want to do Bishop C4 I'll play
um I'll play a standard Italian Bishop
C5 if I play Knight F6 that's a two
Knight's defense but that would allow
for the fried liver
Shenanigans so my opponent is following
opening principles very finely here um
and I will too just
develop develop minor
pieces oh I are we going to see the same
type of sequence I just made note of
this from the previous
game yeah this can go both
ways oh that'll be so funny if we see
the same sequence of Moves Like take
take take
take yeah I think there's a lot of
players out there that um maybe would go
for this move now we don't see Knight
takes F7 so this will be a little bit
different Queen F3
aggressive White's trying to exert more
pressure on my king
side uh with this
move I have a few options I could play
H6 and then question like what is this
Knight
doing and that would either provoke
white to take or probably move back I
could play Knight D4 as well Knight D4
hitting the queen and the pawn which is
not
defended
um honestly I think Knight D4 4 and H6
are both very fine
moves um I think I'll play Knight or
I'll I think I'll play H6
first and then save Knight D4 for
later but it would be totally fine to
play Knight D4 first as
well now we'll see okay so white does
take on
F7 and hopefully for everyone who
watched the previous game in this video
you'll remember the lesson
that the two minor pieces are much more
valuable than rook and Pawn in uh the
opening in the middle game this is
interesting so White's not taking the
Rook because the rook's pinned so I
can't really
easily like Save The Rook
here uh but what I can do I should not I
don't want to play D5 cuz that would um
I think that would walk into Knight
takes D5 and there'd still be so much
pressure so I'm much more inclined to
play this move Knight
D4 and this is very multi-purpose
because I'm hitting the queen I'm
hitting the pawn but I'm also preparing
Knight E6 like if white moves a
queen I might just want to block the
bishop and then save my
Rook so that means that it's probably
best for white to take the Rook although
white doesn't do that now I do have a
fork here but fortunately E2 is defended
a bit too many
times so I guess it's a question do I
want to take the
pawn or save my
Rook I think it's much simpler just to
save The
Rook I mean this is kind of um a
mathematical question like what brings
me the most value CU I would go up a PA
here but I'm allowing the trade
which I
mean generally the The Rook is very
valuable to keep especially in a
position like this where I don't have
the F Pawn so the file is half open for
black and yeah very soon I
could orchestrate some attack on the
king
side some move like Knight H5 perhaps
coming now D3 okay so it's so important
to acknowledge White's idea after this
move as White's unleashing the bishop
and the queen is pinning my G Pawn so
white wants to take the pawn on
H6 and in this position there's I think
a few ways to deal with that I was
thinking I could Counterattack with
Knight
H5 but I think first i' just like to get
the king to a a safer place I like this
move King
H7 because it gets off the file of the
queen and the diagonal of the
bishop wow I just not see the pawn was
hanging I forgot the pawn was hanging I
saw White's thread of this I didn't see
white thread of Queen takes
E5 the funny thing is I think this is a
poison Pawn so I think
there's there's a move for black here to
exploit the
queen and exploit this F Pawn I'm going
to play Knight
G4 now before I play this move I have to
kind of ackowledge that my my Bishop's
defended Queen F5 is off limits cuz my
Rook will be
Unleashed but Knight G4 looks really
nice cuz I'm hitting the queen and now I
have three
attackers against
F2 so that worked out kind of by
accident this might be one of the first
times in this series my opponent played
a move which I just completely
overlooked was taking a free
Pawn but sometimes when you're when
you're fully developed and your pieces
are in good squares in the middle game
then even if you overlook
something your pieces will still be
useful enough to kind of compensate
whatever you
overlooked now in this case we have
to essentially calculate because there's
there's three Defenders of F2 and
there's three attackers
normally when there's the same number of
Defenders and
attackers then the Defenders have an
upper hand because uh the attackers will
be the first to capture but in this case
because a queen and king are both
Defenders and they're the most valuable
things to protect for white um I think I
can go ahead and just snag material um
but I'm debating
between Knight takes Rook takes or
Bishop takes I think
like all all three moves are very
possible here Bishop takes us the most
forcing after which yeah we probably see
Rook takes and I take with
Knight I think I would much rather keep
my Bishop to be aligned with a king I'm
thinking if I take with
Knight it looks good because I'm setting
up discoveries but if I take with Knight
there's Bishop
E3 that blocks my Bishop
not sure if I'm winning much
there so Rook takes actually looks like
the the most devastating move for
White and the reason why is because I'm
setting up the discoveries if Rook takes
I take back with bishop and Fork the
king and
queen I'm going to do this and if Queen
takes
Knight then I'm going to have the
discovery check I have Rook
F4 to attack the king and then win the
queen so a lot of tactics coming into
play
here but the pieces are very much
working
together okay we do see Rook takes and
think opponent didn't didn't quite
realize what's now happening to
them yeah there goes White's
Queen so after after pawn diges bishop
I'd just be up a queen so opponent
resigns um another interesting
relatively quick but instructive game uh
we saw similar lesson play out a little
bit differently opponent went for this
early attack on
F7 and I mean going back to basic
opening principles this is why you want
to Castle quickly to keep uh especially
keep the F Pawn
defended and yeah what ended up
happening was
very fine uh very fine trade on F7 I I
managed to save the rook in this
position if I saw the pawn was
attacked I would maybe still play this
to set up the the tactic with Knight
G4 I'm realizing I'm very thankful I
didn't play Knight H5 because then Queen
takes pawn and I wouldn't have the same
followup so anyway uh yeah hopefully
viewers can learn something from this
game I have officially broken 600 I
think I I broke 600 after the previous
game so let's play at least one more I'm
I'm hungry to get a
Checkmate this is game number five I
have yet to check made in this video
playing sa
saas it's a lot of vowels in a row okay
this game might get
aborted opponent might see my profile
picture and be a little bit afraid
here this baby Rosen too
[Music]
terrifying okay no check made in that
game
all right playing I am alpha wolf good
luck to my
opponent almost mous slipped King E5
there so repeating the same opening now
we have uh what's called a scotch game
Pawn
D4 uh now in this position there are two
viable developing moves Knight F6 and
Bishop to
C5 um I like Bishop C5 bit more active
immediately attacking the
Knight Knight B3 so Knight B3 saves a
knight but also attacks a bishop so very
important to realize White's threat I'll
simply move back to
B6 Pawn F4 okay so aggressive move
whenever white plays this move early in
the game you you always want to be aware
of this diagonal uh now I do have Queen
H4 check right away but doesn't really
do much cuz white plays G3 attacks the
queen saves the king and there's really
no great followup
there so I think this is more of a
question of how do
I just complete development and Castle
as quickly as possible and I think I
still like this move KN
F6 I'm going to play
kn6 now it does look like I'm maybe
walking into
E5 which we do see and I I think this is
good cuz we'll see how this plays out um
sometimes you you want to be very wary
of this move but in this case I have a
couple
options and I don't have to move it uh I
do have Queen E7 to pin the pawn but I
also have Knight
E4 and even though the Knight maybe
doesn't look so stable on e4 I would be
threatening Knight
F2 or Bishop F2 or even Queen
H4 yeah I like Knight
E4 Queen E7 I think would also be
fine sometimes Queen E7 you don't want
to play if the bishop still on f8 but in
this
case um well in this case yeah I'm I'm
happy I played Knight E4 because now I
get to choose between a few good-looking
moves um now I should knowe Bishop F2
looks good at first but after King F1
Knight would be attacked Knight's
defending the bishop I think Bishop F2
is actually a big mistake so it's really
a question do I want to go for Knight
left2 to win material or do I want to go
for Queen H4 and try and exploit the
king I think a lot of players here would
play Knight F2 without much
thought but honestly I think Queen H4 is
way more
effective I mean Rooks are valuable but
checkmating the king is
priceless and in this position Okay the
reason why I played Queen H4 was because
I I saw what to do in this position is
to take the
pawn now it looks like I'm exploiting
the pin which I kind of am but more
importantly
if Pawn takes
Knight I could very likely have a mating
sequence with Queen takes
and this is probably a position where I
have to to use some of my calculation
abilities to see the forcing line so
takes
takes is not happening okay so opponent
moved quickly enough for me not to have
to calulate
that um in this case I have some
discover checks any knight move is check
think I'm happy to take the Rook
unleashing the queen
maybe after the game I can show what the
calculation could have been like King D2
and yeah there is some potential king
walk but in this
case yeah still a matter of converting
let's take on
H2 I think this is an easy move to play
a win a pawn keep the attack also defend
the Knight now it's really about hunting
the king
here white does have a few ways to get
out of check King can Retreats could
move forward Bishop E2 Queen E2 also
legal yeah in the position like this
with the king so exposed and my pieces
swarming I was going to say that I would
really like to go for some mating that
uh like for example Queen E2 would be
met with Queen takes F4 uh Bishop E2 I
probably go for Knight G3 and Target the
bishop King
here King there I actually don't see an
obvious move maybe also move the night
back either here or here so life was
very good there for black um do I want
to analyze so much I think that was that
was another game where like my
opponent didn't really develop
efficiently I developed more quickly and
we saw
how that can translate
into very quick win with the early
attack especially moving the F Pawn
exposing the king can have pretty high
consequences early in the
game now I guess the one line I did want
to show is if takes of course I could
have taken the rook and maybe I would
end up taking the Rook but there there
was a a fun line to take the pawn if
King here or here it's Queen F2
checkmates and if King D2 there is this
check maybe it's not
checkmating yeah this is one of these
cases where it looks really good but
like Bishop A5 there's Knight takes
A5 and then my Queen's attacked too so
maybe good that uh we did not go into
that
line so um I don't want to end it here
because I haven't gotten a Checkmate
over the board so let's let's give it
one more game I think this is going to
be the final game of the video
regardless this is a longer speedrun
episode than
usual but um yeah trying to make up for
it cuz I was absent for a while in this
series and we see
D4 this is one of the first D4 games I
think I'm going to play
D5 and we see a Queen's Gambit so
there's a lot of openings to play uh
against Queen's Pawn or against Queen's
Gambit um I'm going to play what I like
to recommend for beginner level as a
Queen's Gambit declined one of the most
solid approaches white plays
E3 which is very playable it does defend
the pawn the downside of e3 it does
block the bishop but that's also the
downside of E6 I blocked my own Bishop
on
C8 so generally when you play the
Queen's gam declined um it's nice to
employ a setup with the Knight coming to
F6 this
bishop usually comes to
E7 if I move to D6 I could just get hit
with C5 so I'm going to play Bishop
E7 and of course castling can come
early and yeah the setup I like to go
for on the queen side is B6 and Bishop
B7 and then Knight
D7 and this is
I don't know if there's a name for it
maybe the the tarac cow
variation
um is is it's one of the lines which uh
black goes for this queenside F kto but
basically I'll be getting a setup where
pieces are very very
solid White's uh okay White's playing
quickly I should know White's playing
the opening very fine maybe apart from
this
uh this bishop like all the other pieces
are on decent squares Knight E5 looks
scary um this move doesn't do
anything so much at least right away and
I'm going to continue with my
development and basically the plan once
I
play this move now we should note the
bishop on D3 and Queen on C2 do form the
battery against H7 but the Knight
defends h along with the king so it's
not really a threat right away I'll
complete development with Knight
bd7 o I don't think my opponent saw my
knight can
take I will say sometimes this can be a
common oversight at the lower levels is
these these backward Knight Moves In
this case a backward Knight
capture uh so I did just go up a piece
and I wanted to say earlier that like
after my ideal setup the plan is to
expand with
C5 and even though the position is
transformed a bit I think C5 is the the
way to make progress
here white streaming of trading off this
pawn and checkmating me but there's no
immediate threat
so I think I'll make a threat of my own
attacking the Knight also unleashing the
bishop
now I do have some choices I could take
the
pawn but then I subject myself to Rook C
or Rook to G1 and then yeah white could
get some attack on the G
file so I'm mainly debating between
Queen takes Pawn or Pawn takes
Pawn I think I like Pawn takes pawn more
like simply attacking the
Knight and basically I'm seizing a
initiative here cuz once Knight
moves I can keep making threats I can
play D3 I can play Rook C8 I can play
Bishop
B4 I'll play
D3 D3 not only attacks the queen but it
obstructs the queen from defending the
Knight so yeah that's a a free
piece now up two minor pieces here with
a very strong
Pawn
Pawn F3 so I'm
considering Bishop H4
here not sure how much that does like
King King
F1 I think I'm going to play a a more
tricky move like of course the simple
moves to move back
but in the spirit of showing no mercy
Queen
D4 um also oh no my
Bishop
what I'm doing here
is I'm making it so if white takes a
bishop or if white just does something
around him uh then I win the Queen
Bishop
B4 so really no mercy
here now I will say like the first maybe
nine moves of this game were very very
fine from White
but like one of the keys to winning at
this rating level is just waiting for
the opponent to make mistakes give you
free
material and um yeah patience can can
really pay off so in this case I could
take the
queen
although I could also take the pawn if I
just want to be
patient there's another move here I yeah
I'm going to play Queen
E3 it's it's a stylish move but it's
also showing no mercy I'm taking
advantage of the fact that Queen is
pinned
so Queen takes Queen was not legal and
now I take the
queen I do give white the chance to take
the Rook but yeah that wasn't a
[Music]
concern and now are we going to see the
game end in checkmates white has one
legal
move white now has two legal
moves what's the quickest mate probably
Queen takes
Bishop my Rook is still attacked but I'm
happy to
take still not
mate can I set up on pan checkmat no
okay let's just deliver miden one Bishop
Bishop D5 Pawn Camp lock cuz it's pinned
so okay the first
checkmates of the video to conclude the
final game of this
video um I hope that was an instructive
one I think that this one was a nice
example of how to play against the
Queen's Gambit like sometimes you just
want to be solid like focus on opening
principles to velop your pieces in
Castle as quickly as
possible um I went for the queen side
development if my opponent didn't take
and play a move like like Bishop D3 and
Castle my plan was going to be Bishop B7
Knight B D7 eventually C5 and Rook C8
and it's a very harmonious setup for
Black where yeah there's a lot of Pawn
tension but the pawns are very well
supported um yeah the game took a
different route and and of course Bishop
H7 it's uh it's an important lesson for
the opponent and when you
play hundreds or thousands or in my case
like probably hundreds of thousands of
chess games over the course of your life
it just becomes ingrained that the
Knight defends H7 from F6 but for newer
players sometimes it takes a a few
accidents for the the lesson to become
ingrained
so anyway um yeah I think I'm going to
end the video here thanks so much for
watching do stay tuned for the next
episode maybe with every episode I'll
update my profile picture like every
time I I make a significant rating gain
I'll have a a slightly older Rosen to
show so stay tuned and I'll see you guys
in the next one